On est contents !
On est arrivés en France !
La vie est belle !
Salut c'est Vincent
de la chaîne "Partager C'est Sympa".
Aujourd'hui, je suis
avec Baptiste de Bapt&Gael
et on est
dans la vallée de Briançon.
On va aller à Montgenèvre,
située à 1800 mètres d'altitude,
où chaque jour et chaque nuit
des migrants exilés
tentent de passer la frontière
entre la France et l'Italie
Alors bienvenue
à la station de ski de Montgenèvre
que l'on peut voir derrière moi.
Un peu plus loin, par là-bas,
c'est l'Italie.
Et si on est sur
cette station de ski,
c'est que c'est
un des points de passage
qu'empruntent les migrants
pour essayer de rejoindre la France
et avoir le droit de déposer
leur demande d'asile en France.
On a la chance
d'être accompagnés d'Arnaud.
Moi je fais partie
de l'association "Tous Migrants".
Et depuis 2016, on maraude
dans ces montagnes
pour venir en aide
aux personnes qui tentent de passer
qui finissent d'ailleurs généralement
par passer quoi qu'il arrive.
Aussi pour arriver à secourir
les gens le plus discrètement possible
pour qu'elles ne soient pas reconduites
à la frontière manu militari,
qu'elles ne soient pas maltraitées
par la police aux frontières.
On a de nombreux témoignages
qui montrent qu'il y a
des violences physiques,
qu'il y a des vols,
qu'il y a de l'intimidation.
Alors outre les coups,
les menaces de mort,
ils risquent de mourir.
- Moi qui ai skié souvent,
je ne risquerais pas d'aller
de nuit dans la montagne,
je perds tout sens de l'orientation.
- Ah mais très clairement,
si tu ne connais pas un peu le terrain,
que tu n'es pas un peu aguerri
au sens de l'orientation en montagne
de savoir te repérer,
c'est aller au casse-pipe.
Il n'y a pas si longtemps,
il y a un jeune qui est mort...
Un jeune Togolais, Tamimou,
de 28 ans qui est mort
sur le bord de la route
après avoir été aidé
par ses collègues de misère,
qui est mort de froid,
d'hypothermie.
- Qu'est-ce que tu risques
toi, Arnaud,
en faisant des maraudes
comme ça ?
- En théorie rien,
puisque c'est 100 % légal.
Ce que je fais,
c'est de l'humanitaire.
C'est aller au secours de gens
qui sont en détresse
dans la montagne
sans passer la frontière.
C'est 100 % légal.
Ce qui est hallucinant,
c'est la présence policière
et l'empêchement.
Encore ce soir, on est obligés
de se cacher de la police.
Finalement,
on se substitue à l'État.
Ça devrait être
à l'État de venir en aide
aux gens qui sont
en train de mourir
à quelques pas des maisons.
Il faut faire avec les moyens
du bord puisque de toute façon...
De toute façon, il n'y a pas
le choix, il faut le faire.
On n'a pas idée de laisser mourir
quelqu'un dans son jardin.
- Arnaud, c'est quoi
les lumières qu'on voit, là ?
- En face, c'est l'Italie.
Ce n'est pas loin.
Enfin, pour nous ce n'est pas si loin.
C'est une demi-heure
en bagnole de Briançon.
Quelqu'un qui
ne connaît pas le chemin,
qui a peur de la police,
qui se cache, qui reprend la route,
il va mettre la nuit.
Il y a des gens qui arrivent
au petit matin,
ceux qui arrivent.
Ça fait déjà quelques heures
qu'on se balade dans la montagne,
je pense que si on avait
dû croiser du monde
on les aurait croisés.
Ce soir, ce sera "bredouille"
mais bon,
ce n'est que partie remise.
Aujourd'hui, on va à la rencontre
des gens
qui s'occupent du Refuge.
Là on va retrouver
les personnes
qui sont peut-être arrivées
dans la nuit
malgré le fait
qu'on ne les ait pas vues.
Donc, on va voir
comment ça se passe.
Depuis juillet 2017,
on est à 7800 personnes
Do not modify/translate ! ||
qui sont passées par ici.
- Mais c'est genre la moitié
de la population de Briançon ça ?
- Presque ouais.
Do not modify/translate ! ||
Donc, oui,
ça fait pas mal de monde.
Nous la particularité,
c'est qu'on est juste un lieu de transit.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est
un accueil d'urgence
comme un refuge de montagne.
Moi je suis médecin retraité.
On a voulu faire
une préconsultation ici, quotidienne.
À partir d'ici,
on les renvoie à l'hôpital
pour faire des radios,
des examens complémentaires,
des hospitalisations
pour ceux qui en ont besoin.
Ici, à Briançon,
l'hiver, il y a beaucoup
de problèmes liés au froid.
Ils ont marché des heures
souvent avec des chaussures
pas du tout adaptés
dans la neige
et beaucoup arrivent ici
avec des gelures.
Et puis, il y a tous
les grades de gelures :
1er, 2ème et 3ème degré.
Et puis un qui est
complètement gelé
puisqu'il est mort
il y a quelques semaines.
Mort de froid.
C'est ce qu'on a du mal
à comprendre
que la militarisation
du poste-frontière
fait qu'ils passent par
des chemins détournés.
Ils ont déjà traversé le désert,
ils ont déjà traversé la mer,
ils ont déjà traversé la Libye.
Ce n'est pas quelques kilomètres
de plus ou de moins
qui vont les retenir.
- Et tout le reste, ça a été lavé.
- Ok, c'est super !
- Il y a deux paires de chaussures.
Je n'y avais pas
pensé avant mais...
j'en ai encore plein
des affaires.
Ça me paraît normal.
Je sais qu'il y a des gens
qui sont au Refuge
qui arrivent, qui ont froid...
Et ils viennent
de pays chauds en général donc...
- Ils ne sont pas équipés pour.
Autant les aider comme on peut.
Quel a été ton parcours
avant d'arriver ici ?
- J'ai tenté de rentrer vers Modane
et la police m'a contrôlé
à la frontière.
Ils ont tout déchiré
avec mon récépissé.
Et ils m'ont fait repartir
jusqu'à Oulx, en Italie.
Et quand je suis venu,
je me suis perdu,
j'ai pris une montagne qui...
Quand tu as dû arriver
devant la montagne
et que tu t'es dit :
"Il faut que je traverse la montagne..."
J'ai regardé le GPS,
je vois que la France
c'est derrière la montagne,
j'ai dit : "Attends,
je vais traverser la montagne."
Après, je suis parti
dans la montagne.
- Mais tu n'avais pas peur
à ce moment-là ?
- Non, j'étais seul
et c'était la première fois...
Et je ne connaissais pas la route.
J'ai commencé à grimper
la montagne à 2 heures.
2 heures du matin.
J'ai fini à 9 heures du matin.